oh
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
l'émission si on parlait sport votre
nouveau rendez vous sur tv fil 78
pendant près d'une heure nous avons
décortiqué l'actualité sportive dans le
département vous connaissez le programme
il y aura des duels des coups de gueule
des analyses
présentation en musique à ma droite yens
dujarrier tout récent vice-champion du
monde de cyclisme sur piste masters ce
fut un champion d'europe en 2013 vous
avez remporté le titre en regardent
peut-être au titre n'en parle jamais
assez
jamais vous allez arrêter un jour je
commence à y penser
d'accord on en reparlera peut-être en
aux jo on passe à gauche toujours en
musique
c'est l'un des présidents les plus
influents des divines mais je même jean
michel aulas le président de lyon en est
jaloux je veux bien sûr parler de
mustapha larfaoui le président de traque
toujours impeccable vous allez bien ça
va très bien merci
on passe maintenant à droite alexandre
taillefer l'homme fort du handball
yvelinois nouvel entraîneur de l'équipe
masculine de versailles des jeunes de la
team 7 8 78 il ne s'arrête jamais prêt
pour l'émission pour l'émission et on
retourne à gauche et enfin on termine
donc par notre tour de table par notre
spécialiste rugby il entraîne les
billysiens des moins de 21 ans du rugby
club de versailles je veux bien sûr
parler de guillaume nero 9
vous êtes vous est remis de votre
première émission ça va
remy puis je dormirai mission les
premiers duels étaient et à ses bibis
puissance que je suis un bon pronostic
pronostiqueurs prenait justement avoir
parlé donc avant de passer au thème de
l'émission j'aimerais qu'on revoie un
dernier passage de 6 du sillon par les
sports le premier numéro
donc nous avions parlé d'un rugbyman de
l'équipe de france et hédi ben arous
mais également donc de l'équipe de
france écoutez pour moi je pense qu'on
n'a pas les moyens de gagner la coupe du
monde donc bas autant perdre autant
perdre contre les blacks et avec un
j'espère juste qu'on va prendre en
prendre 40 g à la rigueur quitte à
perdre si on perd 2,3 points ce sera
ainsi moins gênant alors après 62 on a
pris 60 et on a été à la hauteur de nos
espérances ou en dessous de tout ça de
prendre que là vous aviez tous
pronostiqué sa majesté riders
je suis touchée mais j'espérais qu'ils
qui pourrait nous créer la surprise
j'espérais quand même mais avec une
certaine lucidité quand même donc on en
reparlera en fin d'émission des
pronostics
ces propositions visent à villé you on
verra on passe aux problèmes de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du skipper tanguy de lamotte qui
a pris le départ de la transat jacques
vabre du cycliste françois pervis qui a
participé aux championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste
nous avons tous mais nous allons tout de
suite commencer par les deux gros
résultats du week-end dans le
département
on commence cette rubrique résultats par
du handball chez n'a encore perdu en
nationale 2 les chaînés siens se sont
inclinés à domicile contre
sully-sur-loire 34 à 30
promu cette année donc en nationale 2 le
chesnay affiche un bilan écoutez bien de
quatre défaites et un nul en cinq
matches depuis le début de la saison
avec santé fr je me retourne vers où
vous est-ce que ce début de saison
compliqué pour pour le chesnay était
prévisible
alors on regarde les équipes qu'ils ont
rencontré les trois premiers matches son
équipe qui sont classés 1 2 et 4
donc ces normes trois premières défaites
sont normales surtout que ce n'était pas
si important que ça ils ont fait un bon
match nul à torcy qui est une équipe qui
a évolué pendant longtemps en nationale
une division au dessus et qui depuis
redescendu en nationale 2 maintenant que
national il commence à professionnaliser
ça commence à être un peu dur pour eux
donc c'est une équipe solide de
nationale 2 ils ont fait un match
vraiment très positif là bas et je
pensais que ça allait lancer justement
pour la suite et pour le coup c'est vrai
que c'est une contre-perf ce qu'ils ont
fait à domicile contre une équipe qui
est une équipe à mon avis milieu de
tableau mais qui va probable voilà à mon
avis surtout à domicile et jeudi
auraient dû gagner
alors tu avais pas forcément avec un
écart important mais aurait dû gagner
d'un but je pense là je pense qu'ils ont
loupé ils ont une paix des points
précieux pour le pour le maintien
maintenant le championnat est encore
très long et et on attend de voir ce
qu'il en vienne vous êtes d'accord avec
alexandre gagnon mais moi ce que j'ai à
garder ses idéaux qu'ils ont rencontré
la dixième équipe du classement
c'est sans que quelqu'un qui était alors
à leur portée maintenant il on va dire
la deuxiéme joker 2
pour rentrer dans leur dans leur saison
puisqu'il vous rencontrez une neuvième à
l'extérieur et comme ils ont fait le
match nul à l'extérieur la dernière fois
peut-être que c'est là qu'ils vont qui
vont ils vont déclencher le qu'ils vont
déclencher prendre la confiance pour la
suite parce que c'est juste un manque de
confiance pour le pur moment quoi stafa
quand on perd comme ça 5 4 5 mauvais
résultat depuis début la saison 4 4
défaites un match nul
est ce que est ce qu'on est tout de
suite dans une spirale négative
est ce qu'il faut en sortir tout de
suite or ce qui est sûr c'est que le
sport quelle que soit la discipline
c'est quasiment la discipline de
l'optimisme sert qu'on se bat pour
gagner on se bat on est des compétiteurs
et on cherche le résultat donc par
définition il ya de l'optimisme est a
priori on est tous quels que soient les
disciplines à le vouloir elle prétendre
au point même on en a prétendu pour
certains la victoire de l'équipe de
france donc l'optimisme est toujours une
sur deux de fait dans la passion après
plus en plus on va dire plus sans dans
le raisonnement la spirale quand elle
est négative effectivement elle entraîne
souvent les gens pour le coup une
spirale négative et vous pensez que les
femmes des fêtes de la même façon que
quand on est devant on a besoin et on
doit rester devant donc par définition
c'est l'écart qui fait la différence
c'est pour ça que quand j'entends bon à
la limite ils sont faits battu battre
sont fait battre par le premier le
deuxième et le troisième
ouais c'est juste qu'ils ont pris leur
place de premier et deuxième et
troisième en tapant les autres donc
voilà donc la saison est longue il ya
d'autres matches on peut survenir c'est
arrivé à des équipes comme les nôtres
d'être dernier de finir premier donc on
peut le dire ça existe simplement c'est
compliqué une compétition par définition
promotion va y viennent d'arriver
c'est en ça que c'est qu'ils m'ont dit
les divisions c'est compliqué c'est
toujours compliqué de lait ou de saison
allait début de saison pour s'acclimater
à nouveau leur handball c'est un sport
de contacts vont se faire face à une
offre il faut s'acclimater à la vitesse
ça va plus vite ça va plus c'est à plus
dur nous avons dû
oui c'est vrai après le chesnay s'est
bien renforcée ils ont eu des licences b
intéressantes qui sont d'ailleurs
performantes et à ses joueurs environ à
sherbrooke c'est ce sera donc si on a
droit à cinq licences vie à cinq recrues
sur une feuille de match et ils en ont
fait certaines très bonne qui sont qui
sont performantes en jour d'aujourd'hui
après si on regarde l'historique du club
il ya deux ans ils sont maintenus la
dernière journée en nationale 3 donc la
saison dernière ils sont montés en
nationale 2 donc c'est vrai que l'on
peut on pourrait dire que cette équipe
est capable du pire comme du meilleur qu
en très peu de temps avec un groupe qui
a pas ce temps songé que ça donc je
pense que je pense qu'il faut pas être
inquiet regarder des deltas qu'ils ont
fait deux dernières saisons pour eux il
faut que ils sont inquiets voilà mais
nous en tant que supporter je pense pas
qu'il faut qu'on soit inquiet eux
maintenant toute façon ils sont et son
compétiteur et c'est certain qu'ils vont
qu'ils vont faire tout pour réagir en
tout temps pour réagir et c'est il faut
pas oublier que le chan est un club qui
a évolué jusqu'en d2 donc c'est pas
nouveau pour ce niveau de jeu n 2
s'était jamais des saisons et si le
barça club voilà donc
et deux c'est une ambition d'y rester a
minima en une de quoi vraiment dessus
fixé un minimum 2 donc y mettre les
moyens pour je pense que j'espère en
tout cas qui vont qui vont y arriver
d'ici la fin de la saison
guillaume alexandre le disais il y a
cinq nouveaux joueurs dans cette équipe
du chéné est-ce qu'il faut aussi
peut-être que la mayonnaise prenne tout
simplement ça c'est sûr beaucoup fait
comment faites vous adore dans votre
club des nouveaux joueurs 5 sur 15 ça
sera comme un petit peu nous on mise
tout sur l'ambiance dans la cohésion
d'équipé soit 3 mi-temps essentiellement
pour quoi faire
mais pour créer là c'est important cette
vie aussi dans l'église pendant leur no
6 et des sports vraiment très proches ce
point de vue là en tout cas on a besoin
vraiment de se sentir qu'on est sur le
terrain on n'est pas tout seul quoi et
que les gens qui sont avec nous on va
tout faire pour qu'on se batte pour nous
et voilà donc
donc c'est important et c'est vrai que 5
sur 20 sur une équipe de entier combien
la carapace ans et ils sont une douzaine
à voler fin qui s'en réjouit pas
forcément tous le match il y en a en
général au moins trois qui joue sur 12
donc on peut dire à peu près un quart
d'une équipe quoi ces normes
ouais donc il faut il faut le temps
qu'il faut tant que ça prenne il faut
tant que nouveau sa 500 tigres il faut
le temps qui s'apprennent imprègne du
projet de jeu qui s'imprègne de tout ça
et c'est vrai que ça met un peu de ton
souvent à asma temps parce que avec
cendres on voit aussi qu'il prenne
beaucoup de buts en ce début de saison
là encore 34 ce week-end est-ce qu'il
faut aussi qu'il y ait des réglages en
défense probablement après toute façon
moins de l'histoire de prendre des buts
pour moi c'est pas un problème si on
marque un de plus que l'adversaire
je sais pas c'est pas un souci
maintenant il faut juste ma carrière
c'est ça et c'est pour tous les soirs un
point de plus sur un but de moussa sow
on a perdu une finale de coupe du monde
pour un point
et puis on a perdu un titre de champion
du monde pour un centième en vitesse par
équipes
donc voilà ce qui compte c'est toujours
devant et quel que soit le quelque chose
est maintenant la seule résultat compte
maintenant il faut juste analyse et si
leurs points forts réellement celata
coupat et et par rapport à ça si ça
l'est à eux d'en marquer plus
si ça n'est pas à eux de défendre plus
parce que la défense c'est quelque chose
de plus collectif alors que la taxe
c'est quand même quelque chose de avec
des caractéristiques individuelles un
peu il n'est donc si on n'a pas les
joueurs pour marquer beaucoup de buts
c'est compliqué d'en marquer beaucoup
quand même
alors que la défense on peut se
resserrer collectivement avec un projet
tactique fort et peu importe son rang
mais dire les joueurs qu'on a donc à eux
de cerner où sont leurs points forts et
leurs points faibles et de et de
resserrer je pense qu'un un peu la
défense a minima mustapha ils sont à
deux points du maintien
est-ce qu'il faut maintenant se
précipiter tout de suite et c'est de
gagner les prochains matches qui vont
arriver où est-ce qu'ils ont encore le
temps
d'abord d'abord faut jamais se
précipiter puisque par définition parler
de sport qu à l'instant un championnat
jamais terminé second on ne va pas on va
pas oublier le football même pour la
troisième tendance aussi dans notre
sport et ça reste qu il s'adresse bien
sûr l'unité d'un groupe par définition
j'entends la défense c'est plus
collectif et l'attaqué plus individuel
où l on connaît bien les avant centres
on connaît bien la structure mentale
d'un avançant de façon qu'ils pratiquent
donc jamais se précipiter
et puis à un moment donné c'est son
propre jeu qui va s'installer
c'est à eux d'en installer maintenant un
nouveau jeu en réintégrant vent voilà
l'égrégore comment on va chercher
parfois dans certaines équipes et donc
là la mayonnaise va prendre mais pas se
précipiter ce sera le contraire s'est
pas cherché à gagner des résultats c'est
la résultante qui est importante
donc on peut jouer sur les mots mais ça
veut dire quelque chose que c'est par le
point d'après qui compte c'est la saison
complète et c'est en ça que je dis que
une dynamique une spirale d'art le
ballet très compliqué parce qu'elle est
par définition inverse par l'eau
cela-dit c'est le différentiel qui fait
par définition la compétition
guillaume quand paul quand est-ce qu'on
pourra quand est ce qu en son sein
quatre a tout simplement la situation du
chéné vous n'avez pas l'air trop
pessimiste pour l'instant est ce que est
ce qu'on va on va s'inquiéter peut-être
à la trêve au mois dé au mois de
décembre à 6 heures sur la fin du match
à lille sont toujours en prison de
relégables à 70 ans mais les cinq
aujourd'hui
enfin voilà il faut pas il faut qu'on
tourne dans une pareille comme ça faut
pas se précipiter on voulait absolument
gagner match après parce que sinon c'est
une pression encore plus fins plus
énorme pour la victoire et dans ce cas
là on déjoue je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
la qui s'applique à faire appliquer
projet de jeu qui en place au chesnay et
et puis ça va ça va ça va le faire s'ils
ont l'habitude de jouer à ce niveau là
enfin si historiquement ils sont où de
nombreux jouets vision cédera ça va ça
va ça va le faire il n'y a pas de y'a
pas de raison de s'inquiéter il faut
qu'il se concentre sur le sol en jeu et
qui joue mieux et quand on joue mieux
fatalement ou d'un boguey en simplement
après le ballon passe à présent au
football en jouer le week-end dernier le
sixième tour de la coupe de france et ça
s'est plutôt bien passé pour nous petit
club yvelinois monde s'est qualifié sur
le terrain de neuilly-sur-marne poissy
qui de cfa corriger un indien sur le
score de 4-1 et enfin versailles s'est
imposé contre grigny par contre où ils
chutent tous vont quitter l aventure
trois clubs au 7e tour de la coupe de
france
en sachant que l'année dernière il y en
avait il y en avait zéro est ce que
c'est une surprise ou est-ce que c'est
logique
yann je m'entends vers 2002 ça dépend du
tirage il faut réfléchir leur dire avons
regardé le tirage
dansez dansez coupe de danser coupe où
il ya des on peut rencontrer des trois
têtes division
inférieur c'est la première chose qu'il
faut regarder les dernières si ils ont
rencontré tout de suite une sino cfa où
tu te rencontrer des cfa et puis qu'ils
ont joués à l'extérieur aussi
on fait un mauvais match bon ben voilà
c'est pas de chance peut-être que
c'était pas non plus aussi les objectifs
pour pour le projet parce que ce qu'on
disait la dernière fois c est aussi que
une équipe qui n'a aucune chance de
gagner va perdre de l'énergie et de
gagner le trophée au final n'a aucune
chance de faire la table de l'énergie
sur sur ce type de match
donc peut-être que on est un peu à côté
enfin peu mieux cotée mais balancer le
balancer le match rapidement pour
pouvoir se concentrer sur le championnat
donc voilà il ya plein de choses qu'il
faut qu'il faut qu'il faut retenir qu'il
faut analyser quand quand on parle de
deux coupes de france une goutte de de
la ligue en foot par exemple
voilà la cfa par an place qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut vraiment féliciter c'est le
beau le beau parcours de versailles mais
il me semble que les dernières attaques
et la plus petite et que petit enfant
mais voilà c'est mais il me semble que
l'année dernière il avait déjà fait un
parcours sympa sur la coupe de sur la
coupe de france soir il s'enfonce à
rennes les enfants régulièrement trois
ans ils font une belle dernière par
contre ils ont été sortis très tôt
ces deux banques devront contre une
ligue 2 ou ligue 1 c'est ça les
attendait ça leur arrive comme
régulièrement ils ont eu chaud contre
contre 30,1 par la sppe et aller
jusqu'au finalement vous avez forgée
cessé de verser cette année voilà donc
les a finalement regroupe les alors la
plus petite équipe quand même pour les
téléspectateurs ça reste comme une dh
c'était le meilleur niveau de l'île de
france et après on passe en passant cf
voilà donc la logique est respectée tous
les autres clubs sont sortis y compris
l'équipe de trappes
mais la logique est respectée
il est vrai que quand on gère une
compétition quand on en gère par an
quand on gère un club quand on gère
plusieurs compétitions parallèles c'est
vrai que la coupe de france en
l'occurrence pour des clubs comme les
nôtres ça reste voilà une manière
d'aller approcher d'autres niveaux
pour le coup on a été jouée des dh alors
qu'on joue en permanence le même niveau
1 le championnat c'est toujours les
mêmes au même niveau même si un
classement c'est aller se frotter avec
trois quatre divisions au dessus ça peut
être très casse gueule aussi très
dangereux donc c'est toujours pareil
c'est assez à bien appréhender dans la
victoire comme dans la défaite
c'est vraiment tirage à guillou qui fait
la différence en coupe de france où
c'est tout simplement le talent parce
que là on voit quand même qu'il y a deux
équipes de cfa une équipe de dh dans les
club yvelinois qui sont qualifiés pour
ce 8e tour sa 7ème tour est ce que est
ce que finalement c'est la logique a été
respectée tout simplement banon ce n'est
pas qu'une question de ça aussi une
question d'envié fanta je pense que tu
as raison je pense qu'il joue de projets
du club sa version si on joue le
maintien dans son championnat on va
peut-être pas cherché à les jouer la
coupe de france et maintenant c'est
aussi une question de tactique je pense
que des équipes de niveau inférieur
peuvent aussi tactiquement imposer une
défense très strictes et c'est enfin à
défendre à 10 en bloc derrière et
imposer ce sera et essayer de gagner à
aller aux tirs au but et c'est de nature
au but puisque après les tirs au but
c'est un peu quand l'autre est la
loterie comme 20 on l'a encore vu hier
sur le match de coupe de la ligue ou la
voilà les tirs au but ont été
déterminants comme au staff en
l'occurrence on
on a vu que château était sorti j étais
mon match là parfait du grand chose à
chatou pour noble art 0 ils ont perdu 1
0 en fin de match sur un double carton
jaune sachant que les arbitres quand il
sort le carton jaune s'aperçoit qu'il
avait déjà donné un carton jaune
probablement qu'il n'aurait pas sorti
parce que c'est devant une faute très
mineurs sauf qui sort le carton jaune
sur un détail qui valait un petit carton
jaune si je peux me permettre
l'expression et il s'aperçoit que c'est
le deuxième qui met un rouge il le sort
et là ça bascule donc ça à l'écran sait
pas grand chose si passion on voit les
images à 7 buts
pourquoi voilà ça se joue aussi à ce
titre à ce type de détails
mais à ce niveau de jeu ce sont les
détails qui prime et en l'occurrence ça
a fait la différence mais il n'était pas
loin encore une fois de au moins de
faire le match nul d'aller aux
prolongations
ce qui est un peu après c'était un peu
compliqué c'était pas très frais dans
les jambes mais c'était jouable encore
une fois je vois la faute à l'écran non
mais regardez
mustapha voilà le décor même le tac est
quand même assez appuyé hier je me
souviens pas d'avoir j'étais spectateur
donc ça fait rêver non j'ai dit que ça
méritait le carton c'est pas le moment
c'est pas c'est pas une faute c'est pas
une agression et à un moment donné quand
il sort son carton jaune parce que ça
met un petit carton comme je le dis ça
mérite un carton il s'aperçoit que c'est
le deuxième et on voit bien que sur son
visage il est emballé ils sont c'est
géré son match pour que ça se passe bien
et s'il ya des fautes qui vont venir est
un carton jaune qui mettra peut-être pas
si jamais ce deuxième carton alors enfin
voila c'est par ces mots durant ce mois
ci mais cela étant ça me le jaune et non
discutable et les bons mois j'étais que
à côté du président à ce moment là c'est
bon ils se mélangent pas tant que ça
nous en contournant sur les terrains
alors il ya tirage au sort de la coupe
de france du prochain tour la coupe de
france qui a été donc effectué
aujourd'hui hier et aujourd'hui donc un
tirage très exotique fois ci se
déplacent à sur le terrain d'excelsior
est ce que vous connaissez le club
d'excelsior moustapha non non pas du
tout petits dégâts site l'anecdotique
sexuelle c'est pour les dix semaines
il est avant avec celle science sa sera
poissy en os et en guadeloupe pas loin
que la réunion donc voici c'est demain
soir à la réunion ça c'est génial tout
frais payés par la fédération font ça
c'est encore plus génial c'est
magnifique
donc voilà ils paieront pas un hôtel sur
place et logiquement il devrait se
qualifier ils affronteront donc une dh
donc logiquement ça devrait passer
voilà c'est qu'en fait que les dom-tom
rendre plus tard en fait un nom dans les
dom tom
ils rentreront d apprendre que non mais
je suis en capacité de jouer contre eux
c'est ça la prochaine fois dès le
premier tour pas tous en même temps
mantes-la-jolie recevra / sont à
iracoubo nouvelle devinette jan
à votre avis irak où le tirage très
exotique en cette année record de
mayotte
non non pas mayotte sera déplacement au
pays basque nord
la guyane donc voilà par contre ce sera
à domicile donc celle il disait cela
augmente iracoubo alors enfin versailles
a vu son match de championnat contre
blanc-mesnil être décalés pour être
remplacé par le match de coupe de france
jusque là tout va bien vous allez me
dire par contre verset rencontrera donc
blanc mesnil en coupe de france donc en
gros il remplace un match de championnat
d'accord pour un match de coupe de
france donc une contre une équipe qu'ils
connaissent très bien
voilà donc c'est même très bien au moins
une passe et donc voilà c'est encore ce
que je dis le tirage au sort a son
importance de ce que l'espace que si
versailles avait rencontré une cfa
au prochain tour serait tard
certainement été compliqué aux passagers
des enjeux financiers aussi tard que
plus on monte
il ya des jeux de maillots puis après il
ya des primes et des bonus enfin il ya
aussi un enjeu
il n'est pas que sportif mais dans la
gestion d'un club la finance comptent
donc il ya aussi des enjeux et rapa pas
faire au stade cette année mieux non
mais rarement coupe de france alors en
coupe de france vous misez sur la ou
plutôt moins avec l'amour c'est notre
hymne points après ce chapitre coupe de
france on passe maintenant la chronique
j'aime j'aime pas de base il rigolé
dans notre rubrique j'aime j'aime pas
notre chroniqueur basile regoli
spécialiste du sport béninois distribuer
les bons points et les mauvaises notes
du week-end dans le sport pour le sport
yvelinois on commence tout de suite par
les gemmes de basile regoli on se
retrouve juste après pour en débattre le
premier j'aime concerne le club de
football de versailles
j'aime la qualification de l'équipe de
football de versailles pour le 7e tour
de la coupe de france voilà quatre ans
que les versaillais n'avait pas réussi à
atteindre le 7e tour marqué par l'entrée
des clubs professionnels de ligue 2
cette qualification vient en complément
du bon début de championnat
des versaillais qui sont actuellement
deuxièmes de leur de la division
d'honneur mais qui n'ont toujours pas
perdu une seule rencontre cette saison
donc je vous présente le jeu donc j'aime
le vert rouge
j'aime pas alors est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec basile c'est une véritable
performance versailles qualifié pour
prochain tour de france
si clairement maintenant parler on vient
d'en parler anticiper sur sur ce que
basile allez allez nous dire ou es sûr
que c'est bien sûr que c'est bien pour
eux après le football le deuxième j'aime
de basile regoli concerne l'équipe de
tennis de table du chesnay j'aime
l'équipe féminine de tennis de table du
chenet qui à ce projet de monter en pro
b en fin de saison
c'est une équipe toute récente qui a
réussi à monter en deux ans de la n3 à
la n1 cette année à l'issue des trois
premières journées elles sont en tête
avec trois victoires dont une d'un
succès récents face à l'équipe d'issy
les moulineaux également favorite pour
la montée en pro b
même principe vous aimez vous aimez pas
vous êtes d'accord avec basile boli à
bagages à tout le monde est d'accord
soit sept heures de voyage
moi j'adore ce sport féminin j'aime
beaucoup ce prix vient ensuite
ben voilà parce que c'est ce qu'on dit
booster une spirale positive et même
quand elle monte de 2
deux divisions et bien contre une gagnée
donc voilà on ne peut que les féliciter
ce qui est remarquable justement c'est
que d'année en année elle continue à
monter et faire trois montées d'affilée
série cette année c'est extraordinaire
ça que j'aime pas à présent basile boli
pousse son coup de gueule donc sur la
politique de formation du tennis dans
les yvelines j'aime pas la politique de
formation du tennis yvelinois
actuellement aujourd'hui la ligue des
yvelines de tennis basée à feucherolles
propose un accompagnement aux jeunes
jusqu'à leurs 18 ans et ensuite c'est la
débrouille
c'est à eux de trouver un point de chute
derrière pour pouvoir poursuivre leur
carrière et atteindre leurs objectifs
leur rêve devenir joueur professionnel
alors certains choisissent l'option de
partir à l'étranger aux états unis
notamment
on a un autre exemple très criants c'est
la jeune
joueuse de beille noisy alice ram et
vice championne de france junior la
saison dernière actuellement 8 100e
mondiale au classement wta qui a dû
négocier âprement avec son entraîneur
durant tout l'été pour avoir une
dérogation pour pouvoir une année
supplémentaire
s'entraîner au sein de la ligue des
yvelines c'est un vrai coup de gueule
poussé vasile rigoli alors vous aimez
vous aimez pas vous trouvez ça normal
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal déjà
programmant la question ça ça est ce que
vous trouvez ça normal vous aimez vous
aimez pas non ce rouge pour commencer un
rouge bien sûr mais là moi je sais c'est
un peu pareil dans tous les sports quoi
dans les yvelines
on n'a pas de grosses structures fin n'a
pas de grosses équipes on a quand même
une ville comme versailles qui est une
très grosse vie est bien le club de foot
local
il joue en division d'honneur c'est ce
que versailles en dh
donc on est quand même sur des petites
divisions je pense que ce type de ville
stud de communes devrait avoir un autre
niveau un autre niveau sur sur les
tables tous d'apprendre la politique de
la mairie
voilà mais non mais les voilà on est
complètement d'accord service à renmans
et a priori pas pour un sport de haut
niveau à versailles
ces choses à versailles pour que la
ville soit représentée au plus ferme
alors il ya château etc
donc c'est plutôt un politique sport de
masse bon bref c est ce que vous trouvez
ça normal maintenant qu'un gamin qu'une
qu'un gamin game média soit lâché 18
entre chez pas logique qu'enfin on doit
pouvoir accompagner ces jeunes jusque
loin que la presse qui même parler de la
fédé je sais moi je mets un bémol c'est
à dire que c'est c'est pour moi c'est
pas aux yvelines d'accompagner des
joueurs depuis 18 ans donc c'est normal
pour moi que les yvelines les
abandonnent entre guillemets par contre
ce qui est pas normal c'est d'un point
de vue de la fédération française de
tennis qui est pas un accompagnement
comme on parle de cette jeune joueuse
pour elle à mon avis devrait être ans
devrait avoir une aide de la fédé
pourrait-on structure à au delà de 18
ans après lutter contre les facultés
américaines
ce n'est pas possible parce qu'il ya une
offre d'emploi derrière pour un futur
boulot et une offre d'études qui sont
quand même parce que ces jeunes là comme
ils sont bons on débourse donc ils ne
payent pas ou ou seulement en partie
l'heure est aux états unis donc ça on ne
peut pas lutter pour pas demandé à la
france de lutter tout simplement donc
en ohio aux yvelinois comité des
yvelines mais par contre pour des
joueuses françaises comme elle qui
voudrait rester en france c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait peut-être un
meilleur dialogue entre la ligue et puis
la fédé pour que j'aie des structures
qu'ils soient plus importantes et s'il
s'avère que dans les yvelines y ait
énormément de bons joueurs bonne joueuse
de tennis régulièrement à ce qu'on m'a
tout apporté un peu plus dead niveau
d'entraîneur au niveau des structures
tout particulièrement à la ligue à
feucherolles ou ou ou ailleurs
on termine cette séquence j'aime j'aime
pas de base elle révolue par une bonne
note base il nous parle du versailles et
à tanguy de lamotte le skipper
versailles
j'aime le versailles et tanguy de
lamotte qui s'est élancé samedi dernier
sur la transat jacques vabre donc c'est
un skipper de 37 ans originaire de la
cité royale qui a fait ses études au
collège et au lycée hoche
pour sa quatrième participation sur la
transat jacques vabre une course du
havre au brésil sur une vingtaine de
jours derrière il ya également ce défi
caritatif qui est de récolter des fonds
pour l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque dans le but de soigner guérir
des enfants atteint d'une malformation
au niveau du coeur même principe
j'aime j'aime pas favorable du sourire
on va pas trop s'attarder sur tommy la
mode car c'est notre projecteurs coup de
projecteur du jour
ce dimanche 25 octobre versailles et de
37 ans de tanguy de lamotte a pris le
départ de la 12e transat jacques vabre
avec sa coéquipière 120 à davis une
compétition aussi appelé au route du
café qui relie le havre à utah jazz au
brésil son objectif est de terminer la
course en moins de dix-huit jours avec à
bord de son monocoque initiative coeur
alors est-ce que tanguy de lamotte est
un héros des temps modernes
tout simplement yann je crois que je
l'aimé beaucoup tanguy de lamotte et
héros des temps modernes
est-ce que sa raison d'être temps
modernes il est pas tout seul un
aventurier en tout cas la vente des
grands aventuriers oui parce que vont
ils sont quand même plusieurs plusieurs
est reparti dans la même arène aventure
donc on peut pas non plus les les amener
au niveau de héros des temps modernes
mais met en effet c'est vrai que lui à
l'avant halal davantage en plus de faire
pour une bonne cause
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque c'est une
association que le choix est depuis très
très longtemps puisque j'ai un ami qui a
été opérée par la professeure qui est à
la tête de cette de cette association
ils font aussi une étape du tour de
france tous les ans pour récolter des
fonds beaucoup de cyclistes partie cycle
à mécénat chirurgie cardiaque
donc donc voilà lui en plus à le
le petit grain de supplémentaire pour
dire je le fais pour une pour une bonne
cause des hoquets ce que vous en pensez
j'adore j'aurais dit je connais un peu
son palace versailles et donc je connais
un petit peu l'histoire son histoire et
je connais sa famille aussi la fin
brasse sa particularité c'est qu'il fait
enfin elles limitent l'intérêt police et
de finir sa partenaire premier c'est de
finir qui a un maximum de j'aime sur sa
page facebook pour que d'éclairage mc 1
euro qui dit pervers c'est sûr pour
l'association donc moi aussi j'ai
laquelle puis très longtemps mais
annoncé vraiment c'est l'intérêt fin
voilà c'est ça un passionné de
navigation
il fait ça pour le plaisir bien sûr et
pour aller à chercher des sensations
fortes mais c'est ça aussi
voilà pour il donne deux sont finalement
de son temps il donne de son sa
visibilité de sa à une bonne cause que
donc c'est que moi je serai génial
et est ce que ça vous surprend qu'à
versailles et soit justement si bon en
voile et il est temps il est grand canal
nonoban un ballet versailles et clermont
souvent vacances à la bretagne vers
nantes ou voilà donc donc ne sais pas si
tu ne sais pas si étonnant que ça et est
ce que c'est vrai et les performances
sportives mais pour répondre à la
question j'ai passé un héros des temps
modernes ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
un héros des gros temps qui sont quand
même parti dans un temps assez agité et
très mouvementée par définition ils vont
affronter les intempéries vont affronter
des grosses grosses turbulences ça même
été je crois
il ya eu un questionnement des abords
trouvait pas au départ même on pensait
même que ça allait pas se faire mais je
suis suivi le départ je pas un
spécialiste de la navigation ne sais pas
ce qu'on tend à naviguer à bien des
égards dans ce que je fais mais c'est
pour le coup ça reste son sport
d'ailleurs leurs spots qu'ils sont à 2 1
pour le dessus sur la jacques-vabre
c'est une anglaise mixte dans son cas
alors c'est vrai que c'est ça reste
qu'un extra ordinaire sas dégâts ou fait
les femmes et d un ouais moi ça me
fascine particulièrement parce que c'est
à la fois une passion qui vivent comme
on peut avoir nos propres passions ça
reste une passion individuelles même si
parfois ils sont en binôme ans au
collectif mais surtout ils mettent leur
peau en jeu 24/24 que là on en train de
parler
on est en léger différé probablement
qu'on sera diffusé je ne sais pas dans
quelques heures
au moment où je parle ils sont sur l'eau
probablement qu'à la diffusion il rompt
j'espère pas où je servirai ou continuer
leur or
leur périple simplement c'est à laissé
dix jours au mieux 10 11 jours au mieux
pour les premiers c'est le double pour
les certains l'idée c'était de finir
donc ces mecs là c'est ils sont dans une
coque comme dans une formule 1 parce que
ça va très vite
ils sont toujours au maximum de ce que
le bateau pour l'heure peut produire
mais également de ce que leur propre
organisme peut donner moi qui sont aux
limites en permanence ça dure une
semaine fin pendant dix jours de semaine
et à tout moment ça peut basculer
et pourtant c'est pour la passion ça
nécessite en plus d'avoir des
financements
donc là ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
non seulement ils ont besoin de
financement sur ce bateau qui coûte très
cher on est à la limite des formule 1
pour la voiture et donc dans leur art
c'est ils sont au sommet et en même
temps il ya cette idée alors bien sûr
que c'est une grosse visibilité pour eux
parce qu'on parle pratiquement que de st
dire que leur action humanitaire
c'est ce qu'on met aussi en avant et
c'est tant mieux parce qu'ils le font
pour ça et je trouve que pour le coup ça
marche très bien donc c'est un vrai
donnant donnant un vrai gagnant gagnant
comme on dit dans le sport et moi
j'apprécie particulièrement
c'est assez exceptionnel et là pour le
coup je parle de tous les bateaux
puisqu'ils sont tous concernés
et là ça nous touche particulièrement
merci alexandre est ce que est ce que
vous pensez que c'est une réelle
performance sportive
est-ce que ça est ce que c'est ce que
vous êtes fasciné par sa performance
moi j'ai toujours impressionné qu'on ait
fait de se battre contre contre la
nature parce que c'est quand même
traversé très très longue coincé donc
entreprendre ce projet là c'est cnrl
réelle aventure avec des réels dangers
et donc à partir de là respect rien que
pour ce à quoi il faut devoir
entreprendre entreprendre tout cela
évidemment en plus quand ses associés à
des oeuvres c'est c'est d'autant plus
louable pour les personnes qui le qu'ils
le font donc alors nous enregistrons
cette émission tanguy de lamotte et à la
cinquième place du classement avec son
imoca initiative coeur on passe à
présent en cyclisme sur piste et
alimente un françois pervis
ligne montrent un françois pervis n'a
pas brillé pendant les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste arrivé à
court de forme pour cette compétition
organisée à granges en suisse le pistard
tricolore a été éliminée pour les élèves
dans les épreuves de vitesse
individuelle
dès les seizièmes de finale françois
pervis a tout de même rectifié le tir en
terminant à la seconde place du keirin
son épreuve de prédilection avant de
commenter cette performance on écoute
françois pervis nous avions nous
l'avions justement rencontré juste avant
son départ pour les championnats
d'europe
cette année c'est une année olympique on
allait les jeux olympiques en août
donc on est déjà accès dès ce mois ci au
mois d'octobre sur les jeux olympiques
pour les sélections pour la forme aussi
donc cette année c'est tout pour les
jeux olympiques et non ça fait trois
années de suite que je suis champion du
monde
si je suis pas champion du monde cette
année c'est dommage mais si c'est pour
être champion olympique derrière y'a pas
de problème je signe tout de suite
yann je me retourne vers vous est ce que
françois pervis a fait l'impasse sur ces
championnats d'europe
mais il a eu raison il vient juste de
nous dire qui ferait peut-être même
l'impasse sur les jeux sur les
championnats du monde donc
la voilà il aurait été très content de
revenir avec un maillot de champion
d'europe
même s'il est très moche
le maillot le nouveau maillot vert j'ai
eu la chance de gagner en 2013 ils ont
changé l'année dernière et il me fait
pas du tout envie donc là on retournera
pas aux championnats d'europe d'ici tout
de suite dans ma blague à part y voit là
il s'est pas du tout du tout une
compétition objectif ils ont ils ont
plein de choses dans la tête ces files
ont qu une seule chose dans la tête
cette année c'est les jeux olympiques on
appris des grosses claques il ya quatre
ans à londres à où les anglais ça
faisait trois ans qu'on n'y voyait plus
et ils ont tous remporté tous remportés
à londres
en 2012 donc voilà on a pris une grosse
leçon là dessus il est hors de question
que ça se reproduise cette année à un
référent 2016 à rio
donc donc voilà il ya 15 juillet qu'une
seule chose qu'ils jugent qui est dans
la tête des gars depuis février l'année
dernière c'est à dire depuis que les
championnats du monde ça qu'à 50 ans
divine dans son passé il n'y a plus que
ça qui compte c'est à dire que là ils
sont dans une préparation qui est sur 18
mois c'était la dernière fois que
françois aller au japon pour faire une
tournée terre il n'y retournera pas là
une prochaine pendant avant et avant les
jeux olympiques
donc là il ya un gros gros changement il
ya il ya une prise de conscience car
eric haïk qui a été fait
il faut il faut ramener l'or olympique
c'est là c'est le seul leitmotiv de la
préparation en ce moment au vélodrome
dit haut ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
justement boycotter limite boycotter une
compétition comme les championnats
d'europe pour se concentrer
exclusivement sur l'échantillon les jeux
olympiques
oui et non oui et non après c'est vrai
que je voulais poser c'est est-ce que
c'est une décision fédérale entre
guillemets ou est-ce que c'est
individuel chacun gère sa carrière comme
il l'entend ou spéciale on leur a dit
qu'on leur a dit qu en gros c'est rio ou
un humain rndh et rien d'autre enfin il
n'y a pas de décision fédérale la seule
chose c'est qu'il ya une logique dans un
sport individuel on peut pas être
présent au mois de novembre
fin octobre pour les championnats de
france et les championnats d'europe est
à nouveau présent au championnat du
monde au mois de février
et puis présent au mois d'août pour pour
l'egypte surtout que à chaque fois c est
encore plus compétiteurs encore plus
performant il faut savoir que le gars
qui gagne les la vitesse par exemple
cette année c'est le gars qui a fini
quatrième au championnat du monde
l'année dernière
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya trois mecs
qui étaient plus forts que l'année
dernière quillan n'ont pas été
voyage alors comment pourquoi la tâche
pour adobe si c'était pour celle c'est
un hollandais peut-être que chez les
hollandais
ben oui il est un petit peu près plutôt
que nos français actuellement sur sur la
préparation et que ben aux jeux
olympiques il sera pas là il est très
jeune
c'est un tout jeune qui du français
motor france il ya été c'est une
compétition qui leur fait d'avoir de
l'expérience juste pour aussi rouler
mais voilà c'est tout c'est on est là
pour il avait certainement une charge de
travail pendant pendant les semaines
précédant qui ne leur permettait pas
d'être aux petits enfants vont bien
charmant et optimum d'avoir d'avoir il
suffisant pour pour pouvoir voir et
trompe énormément je comprend l'objectif
audio ça joue sajou toujours à des à
dépouiller m
1 une qualification pour un championnat
du monde mais je n'ai pu les dernières
entre le meilleur temps et le dernier
temps iliad même pas deux dixièmes donc
cesser c'est un film pour les rageux
thermo sapa non simplement on a parlé
tout à l'heure du championnat on a parlé
des coupes de france on peut parler de
la coupe de la ligue pour les pour les
professionnels on a plusieurs
championnats comme ça à un moment donné
c'est pas simplement le fait qu'il soit
individuel et qu'ils fassent un choix
parce que c'est un sport individuel
c'est calandre il ya des choix à faire
quel que soit le sport un moment donné
il ya des il ya des contraintes
individuelles et les contraintes
collectives de la même façon il ya des
choix qui sont souvent stratégique et
probablement même au delà de la
stratégie de course
il ya peut-être aussi des choix
stratégiques par rapport à la fédération
par rapport à des politiques qui sont
menées par d'autres
et là on est sur d'autres dimensions
après le cyclisme sur piste nous allons
parler volée et des bons résultats de
l'équipe de france
après la ligue mondiale les volleyeurs
français ont remporté des championnats
d'europe en battant en finale la
slovénie 3 sets à 0
la team iaaf bout et ans et pleine
d'audace à l'image du dernier point de
ndiaffate dos au filet on l'a tous vu ça
vous fait rire d'ailleurs yann est ce
que les bons résultats de l'équipe de
france peuvent influer sur le nombre de
licenciés dans les yvelines nous avons
posé la question à deux volleyeurs
évinois c'est des résultats qui sont
exceptionnelles ça fait très longtemps
qu'on les a pas qu'on a pas eu de tels
résultats envolé ils ont gagné à la fois
la ligue mondiale et la coupe d'europe
c'est quand même une première dans les
deux cas pour une équipe donc on a un
excellent au petit peu franchement aller
très loin
je pense que c'est des résultats tout à
fait exceptionnel on a aujourd'hui une
équipe masculine qui a montré la voie
pour le tout le volet français avec une
vraiment des résultats
excellent et maintenant on espère
simplement que les équipes féminines
vont pouvoir emboîter le pas mais avoir
des résultats aussi intéressant c'est
vraiment un bel engagement un bel
encouragement aussi pour tous nos clubs
locaux régionaux départementaux pour
avoir plus de plus d'adhérents et plus
dans vie alexandre est ce qu'une
victoire comme celle-là peut en aider
des licenciés supplémentaires à la
fédération des yvelines c'est évident
mais c'est pas suffisant qu'il va
falloir qu'il soit champion olympique le
jour ils seront champions olympiques là
il y aura un boom exceptionnel parce que
je peux à d'europe s'est regardé
finalement par les initiés la ligue
mondiale qu'ils ont gagné juste avant
c'était pareil c'est pas les initiés
même si ces deux arrêtés quand même
diffusé en clair quand même pour ces
championnats d'europe depuis sa finale
en tout cas juste pour la finale mais on
sait très bien que je sois pas ceux
diffusés en clair que y'a vraiment
tendre personnes que ça qu'ils vont voir
sur justin match alors que les jo s'est
diffusé dans le monde entier
tout le monde sait qu'à du sport à la
télé et on va regarder un peu tous les
sports parce que c'est le moment où
justement on prend le temps de regarder
du sport pour les gens qui ne font pas
de sport et donc je pense que ne
serait-ce que déjà qu'une médaille
olympique qui sera évidemment diffusé
aussi à la télé sur des chaînes
hertziennes sera vraiment un vrai bon ce
qui est ce qui est certain c'est que ça
va sûrement faire un bon c'est une
certitude mais le vrai bon le cap qu'il
faut qu'ils arrivent à passer je leur
souhaite vraiment et je pense
sincèrement moi qui peuvent être
champions olympiques en 2016
et ça sera le cas peut-être pour amener
plus de licenciés vous vous pensez
vraiment c'est léger oh oui là pour
l'instant c'est anecdotique selon pas un
exotique mais pas suffisant c'est pas
c'est bien suffisant il y aura assez
médiatisé enfin le volley est un sport
peu médiatisé en france est le seul
endroit où des sports mineurs peuvent
exister c'est audio quoi et donc si vous
y font un truc
enfin ils font de médailles mais moi
aussi je pense aussi qu'ils peuvent
aller chercher le titre
s'il faut me leila oui là là on va en
parler en france entière il y aura d'une
mondialisation et les gamins iront megan
ils iront au volet parce que c'est un
sport qui nous a fait rêver sinon
j'aime bien que le volley ball c'est un
sport qu'on pratique tous au collège
donc voilà c'est la foi qui tend vers la
jeunesse et donc c'est ce qu'elle voit
la plage vous ça vous arrive quand je
vais à la plage
enfin quand je dis non mais cela étant
ça rejoint la prendre la question
période du cycle il sert que quand on
choisit les jeux olympiques on sait
l'importance des jeux olympiques et de
la couverture médiatique parce que
justement c'est un problème de
couverture médiatique vu à la télé le
tour de france amène des circuits chaque
année plus le tour de france est
spectaculaire pour on envoie des voix
des licenciés la coupe du monde de
football
chez moi c'est le nombre de licences qui
varient de façon de façon importante
après chaque coupe du monde est le cas
je parle du foot donc va donc cesser la
couverture médiatique vu à la télé il ya
un engouement à chaque fois surtout
quand on voit de belles images et quand
on veut j'ai pu discuter un engagement
avec le club de pézilla villepreux
apparemment la ligue mondiale aurait
attiré 5 % de licenciés en plus cette
année et il estime qu'il aurait 10 %
d'inscriptions en plus grâce à cette
coupe d'europe le monde je te serai
encore plus inclusive où est donc
forcément plus haut après notre débat
nous plongeons à présent dans une secte
notre séquence découverte à l'apnée
oh
notre sport découverte nous allons
parler aujourd'hui de l'apnée l'élan
courtoise et des avis delpy a remporté
une médaille de bronze lors des derniers
championnats du monde en italie à ischia
nous en profitons donc pour parler de ce
sport méconnu qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce sport yann c'est votre ami à gaza
ville à pied à cheval et d'épicés d'un
copain avec des potes suffisamment une
mission il veut a dit on à pratiquer le
roller ensemble il ya huit ans roller de
vitesse
ensemble il ya sept huit ans j'ai fini
deuxième de la coupe de france en 2006
et ont ramené non en colère et lui a
fait une deuxième de la coupe de france
en roller en 2007 et qu'est ce que vous
pensez
alors eh bien j'ai hâte de pouvoir le
découvrir
xavier me parle depuis depuis très peu
plus d'un an de venir faire une
initiation il venait à faire une
découverte
il me dit avec les les capacités
physiques que j'ai il peut m'amener
rapidement entre trois et quatre minutes
d'apnée quand je suis dans mon canapé
j'ai du mal à dépasser une minute trente
donc je me demande quels sont les
lézards mais quels sont les
les mécanismes qui permettent d'arriver
à ce type de performance
voilà j'ai juste envie de découvrir de
découvrir ce sport du fait d'avoir
rencontré xavier bien sûr c'est pas
quelque chose qui m'aurait kim aurait
attiré plus que ça avant mais là j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'on va dans la
dans la connaissance de son corps et moi
c'est ce que j'aime dans la préparation
physique
quand je fais quand je prépare un
événement ce que j'aime c'est de sentir
et de voir mes performances évolué et
avancer voir le chrono qui descendent
quand on approche de l'événement c'est
ça qui me motive à me préparer à me
dépasser à l'entraînement donc donc là
voilà je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à
aller aller chercher dans ce sport et
j'ai hâte de pouvoir faire une faire une
initiation il ya beaucoup de clubs dans
les yvelines qui qui le propose est donc
xavier va me proposer de le faire est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres personnes qui ont
testé l'apnée malheureusement parisienne
n'a pas encore testé d'ailleurs j'étais
gamin quoi faire arroser quoi entre nous
et je pense que je manque d'air déjà
ring de vouloir à parler de ce que je
dis ne voir dans ce non c'est plutôt
jacquouille je veux rester à alger n'ont
probablement jamais cousillas des bulles
d'air s'arranger des bulles d'air c'est
un très beau sport qui était ce un sport
c'est un sport à la base physique je
pense qu'à ses intentions deux autres
messieurs hier c'était juste vous
présenterez les échecs ont peut-être
pensé que c'était une tentative de
suicide à chaque fois mais quoiqu'il ait
pas réussi c'est que non mais c'est
dévoiler précieux et voile ex ancien
patient doit aussi vu mon niveau de
performance oui je pense que je me
demande toujours comment ils font pour
être fait autant de temps sous l'eau
donc c'est vrai que ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est de pouvoir essayer de
comprendre les mécanismes qui leur
permettent quand même de parce que c'est
sûr qu'il ya des techniques peu après
avoir autant d'écart avec le commun des
mortels c'est qu'il ya forcément des
techniques et et peut-être qu'on pouvait
le réutiliser pour pour des sports je
pense notamment des sports individuels à
dominante énergétique ça pourrait être
peut-être des moyens pour pour augmenter
ses capacités
retour à présent sur terre je pense que
vous allez adorer mustapha avec un autre
juge le défi concerne aujourd'hui le
football direction le club de football
de trappes que vous connaissez bien vous
y tapas le but est de se défier de
tournai 20 fois autour d'une balle et
2-17 marque un but pas si simple les
joueurs ont testé qui et vous verrez ils
ont eu du mal à me croiser un jeune
investisseur samba 19 ans donc sur nos
mails bateau
chantal malecon d'engorger 24 ans on
m'appelle el matador
nous présente marbles aymeric 22 ans
sûrement honda
barbosa pointe devant aller à ce nouveau
parti
a été très difficile
ça nous fait tourner la tête et après on
sait plus où tu y est on sait plus où
donner de la tête
c'est vrai salaire salaire facile qu'on
voit mais dans la pratique c'est très
très dur si grave il a remporté deux
fois lors du moins bonne guerre ça va
c'est bien j'ai gagné c'est un jeu on
est des bons joueurs tirent tout le
temps les pirates ils s'entraîner chez
lui c'est pour ça aussi qu'on prenne
toujours à moustache je les ai trouvés
je les ai trouvés très résistant les
résultats dorénavant je demande une
autorisation écrite pour ce genre de
test frais sont mes joueurs parce que
moi j'ai un championnat
j'abandonne ma cave de fronde pour le
championnat c'est pas pour faire le
mariole sur le terrain le chien a
précisé quand même que là vous avez
l'assentiment des plus jeunes c'est très
jeune il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas les
vétérans n'y a pas la jante et je parle
des tauliers d'accord j'ai pas les
balthazar enfin balthazar en
l'occurrence des sandales meilleur
vecteur de l'ex en ce moment samba je
parlais des jeunes je tente pas de leur
performance c'est vrai que les jeunes
adorent ce genre de show tirait sur la
barre à faire des petits gestes comme ça
et ça qu'on s'en amuse ensemble mais par
contre on a parlé n'a pas les tauliers
là
les oreilles ça me ferait plaisir de les
voir une prochaine fois d'attenté on
passe à présent au coup de gueule
d'arnaud louwyck notre chronique
chronique à arnaud le gouïc poussera
chaque émission à coups de gueule sur
l'actualité sportive aujourd'hui son
coup de gueule concerne le football
féminin et les yvelines je vous laisse
la parole d'arnaud ils n'y allaient pas
trop fort cette semaine
merci michael donc mon coup de gueule du
jour c'est sur le foot féminin où sont
les femmes
où sont les femmes on peut on peut se le
demander après la coupe du monde qui
s'est très bien passé pour l'équipe de
france s'est bien passé de façon
sportive très bien sur le plan
médiatique avec les audiences qu'on
était plus que correct on s'est dit
qu'il y allait y avoir un engouement
notamment aussi avec fifa 16 qui s'est
mis à faire du foot féminin
c'est assez extraordinaire par rapport à
ce qu'on pensait du foot féminin il ya
six ans revient quelques quelques années
en arrière
donc on voit là une mayonnaise qui était
en train de monter là comme ça et puis
est retombé à retomber ya plus rien
enfin dans les yvelines en tout cas il
ya plus grand chose on avait montini qui
était qui était en d2 car descendu on a
des idées comme en ce moment deux clubs
on a des équipes qui essayent de se
monter et puis qu'ils démontent il est
pilote ça pousse d'un côté puis ça se
démontre
ce qui fait qu on a on n'a pas vraiment
de l'équipe fanion
hormis lé psg qui cartonne en ligue des
champions et en championnat
un petit peu en difficulté mais il
manque quelque chose
il manque quelque chose cette chose
c'est peut-être un échelonnement entre
les u 13 u 16 ans district
après un bref tableau qui n'a plus rien
il ya plus rien après tu fasses
directement la ligue il ya plusieurs
niveaux de liga alors la ccss
il ya des poules de 5 des poules de 12
des poules 2 c'est n'importe quoi
donc il va falloir recadrer ça donnait
envie aux gens de venir voir du foot
féminin ça passe aussi du coup pas des
matchs intéressants pas dé 7,0 pas dé
8,0 pas des quinze 15 2
en dix ans 1re division news bout de
cinq journées avec 34 buts de différence
positive
c'est délirant jamais jamais ça
l'intéressera les gens de regarder des
matchs à sens unique où on en arrive on
sait qu'on va avoir 7 buts
voilà donc si on veut vraiment du foot
féminin est pas que ça reste à l'état de
marketing où on envoie ça pour vendre
des jeux où on envoie ça pour vendre de
la pub les faire genre on a bonne
conscience le foot féminin a une chance
de vivre en france si on veut aller au
delà de ça il va falloir faire quelque
chose
c'est mon avis cette affaire je vous
sers très remonté sur le coup de gueule
dire ne va pas remonter c'est qu'en fait
voilà faut quand même expliqué que le
football moi j'aime bien dire le
football pratiqué par des filles mais
c'est un peu plus long football féminin
pour moi ça n'a pas de sens il ya pas de
football masculin ya pas de sou de fait
bien il ya juste un football ce sont les
mêmes règles sont les mêmes terrains les
mêmes pratiques par des garçons et par
défi cela dit là où il a raison c'est
que faut pas que ça soit simplement une
espèce de deux variétés de volonté de
bonne conscience de dire tiens il faut
combien des filles au foot
mais c'est juste que c'est effectivement
un sport qui est apprécié par les filles
et j'en veux pour exemple c'est que nous
on avait pas d'installations donc c'est
aussi ce prince un problème tout simple
c'était un club comme le nôtre on a plus
mille adhérents licenciés les des
garçons j'ai déjà pas suffisamment de
structures pour faire jouer les garçons
et surtout les douches et les
championnats
il faut les emmener etc cette année on a
eu un nouveau terrain synthétique
on a fait une priorité aux filles il ya
cinquante films qui sont inscrits à
trappes cette année et on a pu on a pu
mettre en place la section féminine u 11
u 13 u 16 et u 19
donc là où il a raison c'est
qu'effectivement les petites ça rentre
relativement facilement à l'école de
foot
u11 u13 c'est relativement simple mais
le problème c'est qu'il faut du temps
pour faire des u16 il faut du temps pour
faire des u19 et que ça demeure donc
c'est juste que c'est un peu lent c'est
très lent parce qu on part de loin avec
le football offre au féminin mais on y
vient en tous les cas il ya une vraie
volonté dans mon club mais il ya une
vraie volonté également de la ligue de
football de paris et je crois par la
fédération française de football mais là
où il a vraiment raison sur lequel il
faut insister c'est ça c'est que faut
pas que ça soit simplement un effet de
manche
une volonté simplement de dire il faut
une parité partout où je ne sais quoi
c'est une volonté aussi des filles
vouloir jouer au foot il faut qu'on s'y
prépare
il faut qu'on les aide guillaume est ce
qu'il n'ya pas trop de clubs justement
dans dans les emails rien que sur 50 ans
ni vignes à trappes
maintenant qu'ils ont souhaité à
montigné à guyancourt à voisins et qu'il
n'y a pas trop de clubs ne serait ce que
sur un périmètre de cette commune il y à
il ya beaucoup de clubs
est-ce qu'il ya pas trop de clubs dans
les yvelines est ce que finalement on en
crée pas trop des clubs non s'il ya une
demande il faut faut les créer
maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est ce serait idiot d'avoir 5 4 ap
cinq filles à montigny 5,6 afin
peut-être après ya des moments pour des
équipes il faut peut-être se regroupent
et avoir une mais finalement les
féminines de tracts étaient souvent des
filles de trappes calais calais parlons
maintenant de l'année irriguer les
autres clubs en permanence à
l'intercommunalité avec versailles grand
parc et peut-être qu'il serait temps
aussi est demandée pour voir des grands
clubs
quel que soit le sport c'est vraiment
pas le foot rugby quoi qu'il arrive de
devoir d'aider peut-être des grands
clubs intercommunes intercommunaux avec
vrai pour les filles les garçons mais
bien sûr avec là je parle le sens
général la question je pense que la
générale sur le nombre de clubs ne s'est
pas faim moi j'ai pris comme ça en tout
cas et je pense que là je pense qu'il
faut enfin un moment donné il faut que
arrêter ces guerres de clochers entre
les deux villes et et cherchait
peut-être à grandir par
l'intercommunalité l'intercommunalité
parlons merci les hommes avant de nous
quitter nous allons passer aux
pronostics du week end
on se quitte par trois pronostics sur la
tradition de cette émission si on
parlait sport même si le trappistes hédi
ben arous n'est plus présent il ne
participera pas à la finale de la coupe
du monde ce sera ce samedi 31 octobre
qui va gagner entre l'australie et la
nouvelle zélande pronostics tour de
table qui va gagner
les all blacks évidemment évidemment
évidemment pour vous pareil on verra des
images ça on ne sait un peu plus mitigé
argué au brh les amis d'un montage assez
facile à jérémy all blacks angleterre et
australie dont mais dans mes trois
favoris donc c'est là que vous en parlez
date du 2 mai oui
l'australie comme c'est on verra les
images non ça dépend des projets
d'efficacité de des buteurs 6 car très
peu efficaces que foley cartonnage
là-bas gagnon sinon ce sera on va à
l'élite vous alexandre jeudi le black
15,9 et william je vais avoir du mal à
me promener c'est un petit peu comme
spécialistes rugby c'est vrai que j'ai
vu les matches le week-end dernier est
en effet l'australie est quand même très
très très très forte
réveillez vous et moi je suis fan des
all blacks donc bien sûr mais juste
parce que je suis fan girl l'acte ma vie
en australie en australie pour vous
enfin on s'intéresse aux matchs du psg
qui s'entraînent du coup dans les
yvelines au camp des loges le real le
psg défie le real madrid mardi 3
novembre
qui va gagner selon vous bah pareil pour
le table avoue moustapha bâ jpg combien
c'est juste parce que j'ai envie devant
le psg
j'y crois pas spécialement non j'ai vu
le log match aller on l'a vu sachs les
scores à l'hérésie
à mon avis c'est un zéro parce que 0 rue
pour vous 1 0 pour le premier jour de la
real 2e alexandre moi je pense trois
programmes et brouillard moi je un match
nul psg real avec un partout ce serait
favorable au psg
voilà merci avocate en tout cas pour
vous promet si confort a rappelé la
prochaine fois c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve le jeudi 12 novembre pour
un nouveau numéro de sion par les sports
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78